-Welcome back, everyone.
We're hanging out with
Will Smith right here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to talk about
"King -- King Richard."
-"King Richard," yeah.
-You're amazing in this movie,
and you're getting a lot of
good buzz on this.
Congrats. Well deserved.
-Thank you.
-But this is not the first time
you're playing a real person.
-Yeah.
-Is that extra pressure?
-It is terrifying when you play
a real person
that is still alive and you know
that they're going to see it.
You know?
-Yeah.
-And it was beautiful.
Venus and Serena were really
excited about the possibility.
And they said that, you know,
they would potentially be
executive producers
and they would walk us
through the whole process,
but they were going to withhold
whether or not they put
their names on the film
until they saw it.
So then I get the call that
Venus and Serena are walking
into the theater
to see the film.
And it's like --
it's the worst two hours ever.
[ Laughter ]
It's the worst two hours.
-"Please think I did
a good job."
-'Cause you spend so much time
creating these things
and there is literally only
one audience when you do it.
I did it, you know,
with Muhammad Ali.
And then with "Pursuit of
Happyness" and "Concussion"
with people that were all alive.
-Yes.
-And it's just --
it's the only audience.
And you just hope to God that,
you know,
you've spent a year
to tell this story.
-Doing the right thing.
-And you hope that they like it.
And Venus and Serena
cried all the way through
and they loved it.
-Loved it, yeah.
One point that I heard
that they thought, like,
it looked and sounded
just like their dad.
-Their dad. Yeah, yeah.
-That they were like,
"This is creepy."
It's like real.
"It's, like, freaking me out."
Like, "This is not real.
It's a movie."
-Yeah. What was really
interesting to me is that,
you know, we all feel like
we have a picture of
Richard Williams,
and it's the classic overbearing
father hammering his children.
But in sitting with
Venus and Serena
and their sisters
and their mother,
it was completely the opposite.
He was a loving,
caring, doting father.
Venus referred to it
as the Jedi mind trick,
that he had somehow made it
so they would have to ask him,
"Please, Daddy,
can we play tennis?"
Their punishment would be that
they couldn't play tennis
when they got in trouble.
And it was -- You know, he
aligned with what they wanted
for themselves
more than demanding
what he wanted for them.
-Yeah.
-And it was a real lesson for me
as a parent, you know,
recognizing that you want to be
in alignment with your kids
versus forcing
and pushing and demanding.
-Telling them what to do, yeah.
-Telling them what to do.
It was a beautiful family story.
It was beautiful.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Will Smith
in "King Richard."
Take a look at this.
-I'm very confident.
-You say it so easily.
Why?
-Because I believe it.
-But you haven't played a match
in almost three years.
-Alright, hold it right there,
if you don't mind.
Let me tell you why.
-Richard, we're doing
an interview.
-What -- What she had said, she
said it with so much confidence
the first time,
but you keep going on and on.
-But you can't just keep
interrupting if we're --
-What you got to understand is
you are dealing with the image
of a 14-year-old child.
And this child going to be
playing when your old ass and me
going to be in the grave.
When she had said something, we
done told you what's happening.
You are dealing with
a little black kid.
Let her be a kid.
Now, she done answered it
with a lot of confidence.
Leave that alone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa.
-That's how you do it!
Will Smith, everybody!
"King Richard" is in theaters
and streaming on HBO Max
starting next Friday.
And his book, "Will,"
is available now.